there is no other day on the american
calendar that reminds us how vulnerable
even the most powerful nation on earth
can be
september 11 9 11.
memories from that beautiful sunny day
in 2001 are still haunting and palpable
america was injured and in shock
then our president came forward to speak
to us
i can hear you
[Applause]
i can hear you the rest of the world
hears you
and the people
and the people who knock these buildings
down
will hear all of us soon
[Applause]
it wasn't scripted it wasn't on a
teleprompter but it was moving
comforting and captivating
even to this day it still gives me
chills
when president bush spoke america found
what she needed
a leader who brought us a sense of unity
not words
a leader who focused on our similarities
not our differences and suddenly because
of his strength america was one against
those who wanted to destroy us
we found our strength courage
fearlessness and the unequivocal belief
that the united states of america is
exceptional
[Applause]
after that we were able to stand tall
and united to confront the massive
violence and hate from radical muslim
extremists who came after us in our own
country our homeland to kill us
i remember that day
as va i was in new york city for
scheduled meetings my security detail
insisted i leave the city immediately
and return to westchester
all the phones were down only police
radios worked people were desperate
looking for loved ones
my own daughter kiki was with a rye
country day class that day visiting the
pentagon
no one could reach any of the children
i called or threw a police
phone i called police commissioner
bernie carrick
and hours later we were able to tell the
headmaster at that school and the
families that all of those kids all of
those children were fine
i set up a center in the da's office for
families of the victims we collected dna
and offered counseling we offered help
from the surrogates court
the family members who came every day
looking worse and worse as time went on
started to realize that their loved ones
were not going to be found that they
weren't coming home
confirmed by the hundreds of empty cars
left at train stations throughout
westchester
yes they took much from us that day
and the riffle effect is still with us
what have we learned in 20 years are we
any safer now
are we still vulnerable sadly
i believe we're more vulnerable
there is a deficit of leadership today
the kind we need to both protect and
chart a course for america's safety
you don't even have to look at a poll to
know instinctively that only 39 percent
of americans approve of joe biden his
lies his ineptitude and his
determination to choose politics and
ideology over the safety of america and
her citizens it is evident day after day
on this one of the most sacred days on
the american calendar we are left with
one of the most feeble feckless confused
inapp presidents
one day he says we won't leave americans
behind
and on the next proudly admits he lied
and says he left only 10 of the
americans behind
then sadly his brainwashed minions come
out and stick up for his lies i am
confident
and we are far stronger and more secure
now than we were 20 years ago we once
again are rising in prominence around
the world as a place of refuge we're
being celebrated we're leading
mr secretary when the british parliament
condemns the united states and when we
vacate bagram air base at night without
telling our allies we're not being
celebrated and we're not leading are you
just stupid
now we have to rely on real american
veterans and heroes going into
afghanistan risking their lives yet
again to get americans out
and while the administration tells us
the taliban is kinder and gentler they
shoot women who don't cover their faces
in the street and they go door to door
looking to shoot anyone working with
americans and they beat
reporters
meanwhile democrats like ilhan omar
rashida talib announced a resolution on
the eve of 9 11 no less to condemn the
hate discrimination and racism and
xenophobia that arab muslims and sikh
communities across america face
lies constantly come out of our white
house days after americans were incensed
about the death of our 13 service
members the biden puppets decide to tell
us they launched a drone to kill our
enemies
in reality that drone killed seven
children they hit the wrong car they
lied to us and said they took out
taliban facilitators
look the satellites we have are so
sophisticated you can read a license
plate from outer space
the same people who allowed terrorists
with suicide vests to be frisked are the
same people who targeted the wrong car
killing seven innocent children
and this administration stands in front
of the american people and lie and say
they went after the enemy that killed
our servicemen despicable
but despite that
you and i have to keep fighting for the
america we know and love in honor of
people like todd beamer who saved
countless lives by foiling al qaeda's
plot to crash flight 93 into another u.s
target the white house or the capitol
building listen to this from the father
about the last conversation todd had
with his wife
so todd was able to have that
conversation with her provide
reconnaissance information pray together
and
ask her to
send his love to his family
because he said we're probably not going
to make it out of this
but then his last words you know
are you guys ready
let's roll
todd beamer and those who charge the
cockpit
are real american heroes we must never
forget
another was chick burlingame whose
sister has been an advocate for 9 11
victims over the last two decades
she sat down with our martha mccallum to
reflect on the last 20 years
this administration is now embracing a
terrorist regime the very people he's
referring to are the ones that sheltered
islamic bin laden
the the ones that provided him a safe
haven while they practiced storming the
cockpits and killing all the pilots
today i was at city field before the
mets and the yankees came and i felt
unity and patriotism again
i felt americans all around me i am so
tired of all this woke nonsense the
creation of division our own so-called
commander-in-chief pinning groups
against each other i'm tired of
defunding police and wasting my time and
energy trying to fight those who hate
america and hate our flag
it is time for us to drown their voices
out it is time for the silent majority
to stand up at the star-spangled banner
and decry those who take a knee i want
to live in a country that understands
that we are lucky to be in this
experiment of democracy together and no
one
no one can ever divide us i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis